the stars come out to support gigi hadid  as she launches her 2017 spring  collection with Tommy Hilfiger I love  him and Gigi doing this together and  it's awesome it's gonna be great you  know I'm so excited for them the 21 year  old supermodel strutted her designs down  the runway in Venice California on  Wednesday alongside her sister and  fellow model Bella and their model pals  hailey Baldwin Stella Maxwell and Joan  Smalls among others there to support  Gigi Cindy Crawford's kids Kaia and  Presley Gerber Sophia Richey and her  family including dad Muhammad and mom  Yolanda her brother Anwar who handed her  flowers during her final walk and Lady  Gaga the pop star sat front row and gave  the designers a standing ovation she  also shared this cute moment with  Yolanda in the front row talk about  major squad goals  [Music]  you